i'm really lucky to be
a c4 israeli global scholar right now
for a few reasons
i'm getting all these skills and tools
right when i need to be most effective
so that i can go to the next level and
it's this
very exciting time but it's also very
scary because this is i guess the last
big hurdle in my career to make sure
that i am established and so to have the
support
of the other global scholars and the
broader cfa israeli team
is really great because i feel like i'm
not just alone
trying to figure it out myself and it's
been super useful
in terms of my mental health and my
research and my scholarship
to have this community together
[Music]
now this unrestricted gift fund from cfr
australia
global scholar program allows us to in
fact
execute on these new ideas that
are often born out of the
interdisciplinary
interactions
sifa as well a global scholars program
really gave me the opportunity to get
mentorship from many weedles in my field
and from around the world so
people at the london school of economics
or people in the us
as well as people in canada so really
created a global community of
people who could mentor me
being part of this in an international
peer group of global scholars
from very different disciplines in
particular those outside
my professional interests was a very
unique uh
learning experience for me so for
example i talked a lot with
sociologists and historians and
economists etc
these are not something that i i get to
do in a regular institution for example
because
the rest of people are physics people or
astrophysicists
and this is something i've been really
enjoying with this global scholars
meeting
this has surpassed all my expectations
i would not have expected something like
this three years ago
this is a wonderful experience